hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina we're to bring you this
week's review for Marvel agents of
shield season 1 episode 7 Fitz and
Simmons are separated we learned what
kind of sandwich Fitz enjoys a little
bromance trip ensues like you know what
you think what this week's of us all the
most important thing to take from this
episode is to trust the system trust
this rust this is Victoria hand created
by brian michael bendis yeah get out of
India deodato so no link it's a Marvel
Universe expansion yeah first well let
me just say that I think I've been maybe
a little more forgiving of the show then
you have I know we've talked a lot about
the show I've been watching this a hard
one um I agree with a lot of the things
that were said about the show I think
like this whole like villain of the week
and stuff I'd like a bigger story or
something and it seems like with this
episode kind of seeing that a little bit
i thought last week's episode was
definitely a step in the right direction
yeah this episode maybe not as strong I
know but nonetheless I still enjoyed
much better than like the previous
episodes or like the first like 45 or so
yes what was it bad i mean we brought a
little bit you know Mike Cena help us
out you know dennis is not feeling well
under the weather so everybody and I
wish them to get well soon she can get
back up here and share his opinion as
well so I liked they'll be a little more
the Marvel Universe in this one not only
Victoria Hammah also get some of the
guys i went to mispronounce his name one
of the agents from the Marvel just some
of the short movies and Jasper I know
this is first day we get Jasper a little
more than Marvel Universe in this yeah
we don't next week big thing next week
good to get the Thor episode i believe
so hopefully this will be the episode
that kind of really right gets
everything alright i just hope it
doesn't go Clouseau kufo are so close to
throw that were like wow I mean the
throne would be so much better but no
we're gonna get a little earth or so
it's expanding its get a little better
mean I don't know again this episode I
mean we see Simmons is doing you know
shoots one of her superior officers yeah
it's goes out in the field with war on
the field war yeah I think that they're
attempting to try to start to flush out
these characters yet more natural cure
development this episode at least give
us some more time alone less sky this
week less guy although she was conceded
play kind of an integral role in this
episode it's all about like secrets and
it's all about like you know chain of
and she basically trying to buck the
trend and stuff you know what I mean and
try to you know help her her co-worker
co-workers her teammates right so I like
that but I feel like again with sky
they're talking about her parents you
know the redacted files and stuff and I
feel like again with her same thing
trying to build up a backstory which
seems to maybe lead into maybe something
bigger yeah I thought at first I mean I
think the age difference really too
close busting on me now Melinda I was
like maybe that could be here about but
I was like no that would be that's the
way she was acting what you heard the
news yeah well also at the end of that
episode you did see that it was uh there
was a photo yes I'm was clearly dead
right so you know and so again it would
obviously you know you see it's playing
a bigger part it's gonna be a bigger
role in the same thing with like Coulson
you know trying to find out about his
trip to Tahiti right you know and so I
like what they're doing with him and
again I think he's the most interesting
character but I mean then again I mean I
liked him in the Avengers films right I
was really curious to see what people
think what you think about Agent Coulson
is I'd liked him in the Marvel movies
cuz he kind of had he was funny and he
had some comic relief but yeah I'm just
kind of a small part of it yeah I'm not
sure I'm kind of feeling at times he may
be overkill yeah I think Riggs a great
actor it's not he's not anything wrong i
just think it may be too much Coulson I
think they might be forgetting what his
character is all about I get that
they're trying out this is a show we can
like really take her time I was a secret
girly ya know if I want to know too much
about Coulson that's true but I also
felt like he was also fun in those films
right and like you said he was a lot
more fun and this but I feel like
there's only a few moments where he's
fun where most of the time he's just you
know hard-ass we're kind of losing right
like who is character is now I don't
know if that's a direct result of what
happened in the Avengers about him dying
you know what I mean it's changed them
to some extent I don't know what could
it be vision I don't know cuz even we
know he supposedly killed him you know
up in the is the one saw the Helicarrier
I called the Triskelion the Helicarrier
yeah okay I liked when uh even then he
made a joke yeah Charlie shot low key
with that gun oh that's what it does
there's exact he's always making jokes
here's a little bit darker but like you
said he's not him he like it was last
week got the physical done yes so he's
not trusting who he is absolutely and
again
it could he be vision who knows you know
what are you through it said vision you
didn't really see him as a vision well
definitely not like the traditional
vision you know what I mean now of
course this is you know the Marvel films
and stuff so they're gonna be they're
gonna take their liberties and change
things now whether or not that's true it
could work out but I just I just don't
see how I don't know right let's see I
mean yeah so I mean those are in our
thoughts for this week's episode let us
always think about the whole vision you
know scenario maybe Coulson be
envisioned let us know what you think
about Thor you know check out Dennis and
I did a review of that you know loved it
both enjoyed it also it might be the
Thor episode next week so what are your
theory on the sheriff less your theories
on what is gonna happen with the Thor
with what's gonna happen so be good trib
you guys should be good so as always you
come childís on thank yo calm you can
also find us on this YouTube page right
here to think you're a pro we're also on
Twitter boot out with michael dennis
myself or at think hero i'm at griffin
de and i'm at mr. Michael Alexis and as
always we also have a Facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think your
fans makes you spread the word give us a
like this video thumbs up subscribe to
think you're a pro and you know I spread
the word keep it going